hey guys do you know what vanity really
is you know a lot of times people say oh
that guy's So Vain this girl is so vain
but do they know what vanity actually
means
some use it for two different things the
Oxford dictionary says it can mean one
excessive pride in or admiration for
one's own appearance or achievements for
example it fluttered his vanity to think
I was in love with him
two the quality of being worthless or
futile for example the vanity of human
wishes
now in this video I'm going to talk
about the first one now is it wrong to
be vain
of course it is
these days people are becoming vainer
and vainer and Vayner lovers of self
more selfish and arrogant walking on
other people not caring who they hurt
just to try and achieve more success
they lie steal cheat and bribe to get
more money better clothes a bigger house
a faster car and then they have the
audacity to praise themselves for
achieving success
and then
at the end they die with nothing
they are no more and no one will even
remember them hundreds of years from now
but they left this world worse than
before
and you know this is nothing new this
happens generation of the generation of
the generation and
nobody learns the lesson it's a big
chase after nothingness
and you know you might be Vain and not
even realize it
because people today think it's normal
one of the wisest men who ever lived
said this Ecclesiastes 1 verse 2 all is
Vanity
what does man gain by all the toil at
which he toils Under the Sun a
generation goes and a generation comes
but the Earth remains forever
now examine yourself to test yourself
just to see if you are vain I'm gonna
ask you five simple questions
all you gotta do is answer them
truthfully
one open your Instagram page what do you
see is it full of selfies where you want
to look good and need the approval of
other people wanting them to think or
tell you that you are good looking
if it is you might be vain
two do you talk about yourself a lot
boasting about your achievements if you
do you might be vain
three do you feel that you always need
to wear the best and most expensive
clothing to look good and better than
other people
if you do you might be vain four do you
often make up stories and tell people
that you are rich or telling them about
your success
then you might be vain
five do you look down on people who are
poorer than you or who have less
knowledge than you about a certain topic
well then you might be vain
if you are Vain and you've just realized
this now then there's still time to
change if you don't want to be that guy
you know that guy who thinks he's better
than everyone else
not because he really is but because
that's the opinion that he created about
himself in his own mind and he always
feels the need to tell others that
he elevated his own self-worth not based
on facts but just based on that's what
he wants to believe
this kind of guy is the worst of all
disagreeable dismissive condescending
and while just plain arrogant and rude
to those around him
and you know people who look down on
other people
who are vain they are the saddest of all
why
because they are the most empty inside
vain actually comes from the word Venus
the Latin word
which means empty
most guys who call themselves alpha
males are also vain because they elevate
themselves in their own minds and feel
it is important to say to other people
that they are alpha males
men listen up you cannot Define yourself
in the clothes you wear the car you
drive or the house you live in I used to
do modeling all over the world for many
years and I've never in my life seen so
many vain people in the fashion industry
it was actually a crazy time but they
are there are a lot of good people as
well but a lot of them are so vain
defining their self-worth by the clothes
they wear the brands Louis Vuitton
Armani Gucci Prada Rolex and the list
just goes on if you wear these Brands
because you think this will make you a
better person you're living a lie
because it doesn't automatically make
you a better person that's just crazy
thinking and rich people who think that
they are better than other people
because they have money more money than
others
they're the worst of all
especially when you look at the way that
they treat others just because they
think they're in a higher Clause it
shows you the Evil Within man
to treat others
like nothing just because you think you
have more money and more clothing a
better house a better car
Ecclesiastes fibers 10 says he who loves
money will not be satisfied with money
nor he who loves wealth with his income
this also is Vanity
you know this is why Jesus said it is
easier for a camel to go through the eye
of a needle than for a rich person to
enter the kingdom of God
you know there are rich people out there
that's actually helping other people and
they don't think that they are better
but I'm talking to the few who think
that their belongings what they own
elevates them for some reason
that is Vanity
they have too much pride excessive
admiration for themselves for their own
class in society and the same goes for
those who fall in love with their own
appearance
I know a lot of models but you always
meet those
that just think oh man look at me I'm so
beautiful
Proverbs 11 verse 2 when pride comes
then comes disgrace but with the humble
is wisdom
you know I've met many people who say
that they are Christians morals as well
and then when you look at their
Instagram it's all oh look at me at this
angle oh look at my lips oh look at me
in this bikini oh look at this angle
here of my abs
they can't look at themselves
objectively anymore they don't even see
what they're actually doing
because they're so used to it and think
that it is fine proverbs 31 30 says
charm is deceitful and beauty is vain
but a woman who fears the Lord is to be
praised
and this is the same for men you know
I've been called vain as well when I was
younger and here's the truth I was
I was vain until God opened my spiritual
eyes and I saw myself for what I
was at that time a wretched arrogant
human being
I felt like the worst person ever when
God showed me my pride
and since then I've learned that
temporary things like looks and material
possessions mean absolutely nothing in
the long run so yeah guys I was very
arrogant before I became a reborn
Christian and then God showed me who I
really was you know it's like you have a
mask on and you take it off and you look
at the mirror and you're like ah this
what I really am
that's what happened to me
but thanks to God he changed me and he
gave me wisdom
we came naked into this short temporary
world and we will go out of it naked
now even though this is true everything
that I've been talking about about
vanity even though this is true it
doesn't mean that you should just sit
back and do nothing
because that is just being lazy
undisciplined Paul said in 1 Corinthians
9 verse 27 but I discipline my body and
keep it under control
spiritual training is a lot more
important than training your physical
body but training your physical body
also has some value while you are here
on this short temporary world you need
to take good care of your health Paul
said this to a young man Timothy who he
trained 1 Timothy 4 verse 8 for wild
bodily training is of some value
godliness is of value in every way as it
holds promise for the present life and
also for the life to come you see bodily
training is important for this life
right here right now for your health to
take care of your body because you only
have one body in this life you don't get
another one
but
you need to think deeper than that just
have your outward looks and the things
you wear focus on what's going on inside
of you
spiritual training is a lot more
important because that is it doesn't
just have temporary value it has Eternal
value
A.W Tozer said what would a violin solo
sound like if the strings on the
musician's instrument were all hanging
loose not stretched tight not
disciplined
you have to be disciplined and take good
care of your body which is the temple of
God if you are a Christian so eat
healthy dress good and groom yourself to
look neat professional
and I'm sure your wife will also
appreciate it you can't be just lazy and
don't care you know a lot of guys when
they get married they think all right
I'm married so my wife she should not
divorce me she cannot especially
Christians and then they just get fat to
be straight and honest with you guys
they don't care
and then they want their wives to do the
effort to look good but they don't have
the discipline to do it themselves
now guys
at the end
you need balance
with almost everything in life don't be
vain but don't be lazy and undisciplined
either
be humble be presentable at all times
self-respect
remember we are guys we need to be
straight with each other honest that's
what I'm talking about vanity about
being lazy undisciplined if you're weak
in those areas it's time to change
improve yourself have some self-respect
and if you want more tips check out
these videos here and I'll see you there
and always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
Church guys